hey geeks it's the boys inu and today i
have the ipad mini 2021
and we're going to test some games on it
and i know the ipad 9 video you know
genji wasn't on 60fps
pubg was on the highest settings i'll
address that in a bit so this ipad mini
it runs an a15 chip and you can expect a
lot of power coming from this small
package so we're going to run a couple
of games on it we're going to run ken
chin cop mobile pubg
and two new ones on apple arcade
castlevania and lego star wars bedtools
[Music]
so before we get into that you know
here's the ipad 9 stuff first
right it's there the ipad 9 if you can
see it's right there yeah ipad 9th
generation you see that so yes no bs
there it is
all right so against impact everything
is on the highest 60 fps
so let's try it out
so against your impact on the ipad 9 you
can definitely play it
okay so graphic settings for pubg on the
ipad 9 ultra hd
ultra frame rate i like this one
anti-aliasing f4
shadows enabled you know everything
looks great lobby ultra hd ultra frame
rate same thing
full time shadows enabled quick match
alright so getting the lobby you know no
frame rate drops nothing
graphics look fine the sun is nicely
reflecting off the leather jacket
shadows are great nothing much to
complain about
and the models look
all right
everything looks great no frame drops
whatsoever
all right so
pubg works fine on the ipad 9.
now that that's settled let's get
straight into the ipad mini so for all
you skeptics out there you know this is
definitely the ipad mini 2021
hands are here and you know nothing's
being photoshopped or anything
it's the real deal so the first game
we're gonna play is ganchin impact and
learning from the last video we're gonna
set everything to the highest so let's
do that and also 60 fps
so it's on the highest you know
everything is on high high high high
high
fps is 60.
right everything's there you're happy
now okay great
so we're gonna do this we're going to
get into a fight and we're ready in the
fight oh close one
oh
totally forgot about that move
oh yes
let's see him again
let's take this guy down
cool
okay
so the responsiveness of the screen for
the ipad mini it's about the same thing
as ipad 9 it's really good so like
i don't think you have an issue with all
the games we're gonna play today
and in terms of performance you know the
ipad mini is holding up pretty well not
gonna lie
decree
the ipad mini can pretty much handle
genjin at the tires so like there's no
issues here at all
okay so we're at the loading screen
right now ghost looks great as always
and let's go to graphics real quick
graphics and let's go for uh let's go
for the very high and let's see that
and of course you can't run the graphic
quality setting and frame rate at the
highest at the same time
you know as you can see down here so
i'm gonna go with very high of graphic
quality and let's just see how the frame
rate holds up then
all right so hopping into a game you
know everything looks great so far
screen is responsive as always you know
details on the scope are magnificent
so yeah everything looks fine you know
no frame rate drops or anything so fast
so let's just see how it holds up in an
actual game
so yeah of course playing an nfps on the
ipad mini it's a lot more manageable
than the ipad 9 so
this is great so far i'm expecting some
good results from this thing
let's go oh
nice
but yeah so playing the game so far you
know everything is pretty smooth i don't
see any frame rate drop so far and i'm
not expecting any frame rate drops on
this thing so i think we should be good
for the entire game
one
two
three
oh my god they're actually good in this
game
oh my god okay someone actually had a
nuke
oh and the game ended before
wow okay
so final thoughts on cod mobile and the
ipad mini you know it works
you don't need to worry about anything
this video is brought to you by logitech
here at geek culture gaming is a way of
life and we always enjoy dishing our
headshots with the logitech g pro x
super light mouse the lightweight
wireless mouse combines excellent
performance with a classy no-frills look
designed with pros and engineer to win
it offers crisp and responsive clicks
the smooth operator even allows you to
swap out the magnetic dongle storage
compartment for greater gliding ease
check out all of its other features over
at
logitechg.com right so of course we have
the pubg in this video so
settings
and then graphics and ultra hd
ultra frame rate
and movie
water reflection enabled anti-aliasing
is at full
and okay
let's just
jump into a match
okay approaching the result
tip
yep
oh people
hold on
i can't see where they are and just
let's just go down
okay
it's all final frame rate everything
looks fine i think our friend is getting
oh never mind my friend killed the guy
it's all good
oh never mind
let's just jump into fps mode real quick
um
weapon models look like
weapon models weapon models look great
oh we got it you know we got people
great
oh i see them
oh damn it come on friend help me out
friend
never mind
wow
well i suck to do
so in spite of my lackluster performance
over two games
pubg works fine on the ipad mini
okay so we have mobile legends queued up
and let's just go straight to the
settings
yup graphics on ultra still hidden by
the downloading resources
widget here but you know that's fine
so let's see
what we can do with this ipad mini with
mobile legends
[Music]
yeah attack animations are smooth you
know you don't worry about anything
let's get this guy real quick and we got
him
oh he almost got me there almost
[Applause]
[Music]
oh i think he's lagging
hold on
we got him again
dude that's not learning his lesson
let's just get this guy
i think overextend again
of course you
and this dude
get help
my god
this is literally cyber bullying
oh my god
come on
brother
relax
okay let's look at this
[Applause]
you guys are getting trashed by nana
jesus christ
coming out you know 14 and three assists
with nana of all characters
i can just say the ipad mini you know it
being super comfortable to play on will
help you win more games i can guarantee
that
so you're playing a new game on apple
arcade
it's not really a new game you know it's
it's castlevania with a boy yellow card
so
let's just get right into it
oh yes my boy other card
if you guys haven't watched the netflix
series please do it's super good
[Music]
okay cool
cool
oh hold on
[Applause]
[Music]
very nice
oh okay we've hit the first level
amazing
castlevania works fine on the thing it's
super smooth and like they did a really
good job with the touch controls
so yeah you can play this thing
moving on to the next game
yeah so we have lego star wars battles
up on the screen and
[Applause]
[Music]
it's in portrait mode which is fine
so let's just try it
out here
[Music]
[Applause]
nice
all right
oh my lord
let's just send an att this way
i wanted to win the game
[Applause]
yeah we won the game
pretty quick battles you know
enjoyable
kind of fun everything looks smooth
it's good
this thing is super comfortable to play
on it's really compact it's small you
can bring anywhere with you it's not as
bulky as the ipad 9 and that a15 chip on
inside you know it's it's going to do
you a lot of favors
so whether you're playing gangshin pubg
or mobile legends or the other games we
mentioned
you guys are definitely gonna have fun
with this thing
also we are using the
256 gigabyte model i would say this
device is pretty good
for mobile game streamers i know you
guys are out there especially since you
mobile game streamers are there stream
for hours on end this ipad is super
comfortable to hold and look at while
you game
so combining the a15 chip
and
256 gigabytes with the space you're
gonna have a lot of gaming and you're
gonna have a lot of clips
gaming on the ipad mini is a definitely
yes
anyway guys if you have any questions
about the ipad mini please leave them in
the comments down below we will do our
best to answer them and let us know if
you are going to get one for yourselves
anyway
hope you enjoyed the video please leave
a like and subscribe to us if you
haven't that helps us out a lot this is
your boy xenio and i'll see you guys in
the next one
[Music]
[Applause]
you